all right tanner i'm coming your way
first because this marks your first big
role on a tv show so two per question
here one what is something about working
on the wilds that like just felt right
to you the second you hit set something
that made you believe like i'm here i'm
doing it and i'm i'm made for this but
then on the other hand what's something
that required a little bit of a learning
curve that you had to adapt to
well flat out just um it's gonna sound
super corny it's gonna sound super
cheesy but
when i
did my first scene with reed
like that was really the time where i
was like yeah
i'm i'm i'm meant to be here just
because
we fell into our characters
so easy so quick and we like we were
hanging out outside of filming and it
was just like i had to pinch myself
sometimes because i'm like i'm making a
great friend and
we're playing best friends on tv
what are you kidding me this is great
um and uh
what was the second part of the question
i'm sorry a learning curve something
that maybe you didn't expect and you had
to adapt to doing like
group scenes because like a lot of the
time like with my dialogue it's mainly
to read but when we're all together
and there's a lot of dialogue and we're
all going back and forth like the timing
and like feeling out everybody's
um everybody's moves and everybody's
sort of
aura i guess
is is difficult but you know like you do
it a few times you sort of get used to
it but
that was probably my biggest learning
was my was
was just trying to get a handle on
everyone at the same time all right i
was doing my homework on youtube so i
was reading a little bit about you know
your musical theater training going on a
broadway national tour all that
wonderful stuff
what inspired the shift to screen work
and even with all that stage experience
is there anything about what it takes to
shoot a tv show or a movie or anything
on screen that surprised you
uh i think what inspired it was just
like a hunger for from you know more
opportunities to entertain i i i that's
just like the type of person that i am i
love to entertain put smiles on people's
faces and so
after doing the tour and stuff my
parents and i we decided to move to los
angeles and
see what i could get going you know what
i mean like my parents were very
very real about like wanting me to
continue my life as well as trying to be
in the industry so i didn't just get
bombarded by the industry and stuff um
what was the second part
second part of this i don't even
remember uh
you have all this uh experience acting
on stage but what is that what's
something about what it takes to act for
the camera that felt different um
i i actually am going to agree with
tanner on that when like finding the
groove with with other actors because
you know like we've all come from
different places like i i did a lot of
stage stuff
some of the people in the cast went to
drama school some of the people in the
cast just you know were just acting and
somehow found themselves on the wilds
you know what i mean and so i like
finding that rhythm with the cast and
sitting in table reads and and trying to
get that locked down so that you can
create a great piece of work um it's
definitely a
challenge but not in a negative way it's
it's sort of the fun of it you know it's
like okay
we here together like what can we do
let's make some magic you know
cast chemistry on this show delights me
to no end they set a pretty damn high
bar in season one i'm like i don't know
if you guys could do it again and see
well crush it also one of my favorite
parts of uh of your characters is how
like they they feel very purely your own
to me like no other actor on the planet
could have played them the same way and
i'm sure you're working with wonderful
scripts here but can you name something
that is like purely you whether it was a
wardrobe choice you weighed in on you
know piece of dialogue you changed
something that was inspired by a choice
you made on set um
the the volume level
of scotty sims
is damn near yelling
all the time that is something that i've
tried to work on my whole life like when
i was a kid i used to get in trouble for
talking and like doing too much you know
and as i've gotten older you know people
like to be more chill like like to have
more of a poker face i feel like scottie
don't know when to shut up
uh and i i feel like that's my fault
it works it's like
hey that that's up to you
i would say probably like the the the
thing that's mine that i
that i brought to beau would be
what is it um
i realized like watching myself on
camera i have like a distinct like what
i'm thinking i put my hands on my hips
so like whenever bo is thinking he puts
his hands on his hips and every time i
saw that i was always like oh i do do
that
there's so many things in the season i
was like when
do i do that is that when i don't
remember that
pairs perfectly well with your
characters gana loved every ounce of it
all right for the end of this i'm going
to put up the spoiler warning so you
could talk about everything you want
freely and we will save it until the
appropriate time but first thing i
wanted to know for you too is you know
just for your own heads did you after
did you ever have to come up with
exactly how you know bo and scotty first
met each other and you know how they
figured out that they clicked so well
together we talked about it a little bit
i mean like when we first kind of got
into it we didn't really know the the
back story but i know that in i guess
we're doing
spoilers now in
in your interview or in your uh
interrogation
you talk about what is it like uh double
cheese fries at jerry's
capcom
so
after we after we kind of figured that
out we
sort of just figured like they probably
met when they were
in elementary school or something
happened but
we never really sat down and said this
is what
happened yeah it was it was sort of a
thing of like we know
we know what we know what it is you know
like you might you're my role dog like
and and and that went a long way because
we were already like we were already
friends it was almost like we partnered
up the friendship that was budding in
real life with the the friendship that
was written and it sort of
worked out on screen how it worked out
you know the show doesn't need those
specifics on screen but when i really
believe in a connection and get a little
obsessed with a group of characters i
feel like the need to know everything
like give me every detail that's what
future seasons are for um
before they kick me out of here a very
specific question for you tanner because
i get a little obsessed with uh you know
like silent moments on screen where
there's no dialogue but you could see
the wheels and a character's head
turning and one that really struck me is
when you two are in the house and you're
watching scotty first you know start to
smash stuff and then he hands you the
mallet and i feel like i could feel the
weight of the thought process going
through his head so can you kind of walk
us through what it was like playing a
moment like that and having it feel you
know so loud and powerful but without
the dialogue to actually explain what
he's going through yeah i remember that
was a big
moment like when i when i read that like
first of all that was just a fun day to
film and uh there were a lot of emotions
going through both of us like like my
favorite thing about working with reed
is that we we check in with each other
and we let him like look at each other
in the eyes and then we'll go
the moment for that i remember
thinking like this is the first time
we're seeing beau
angry
and that's a big deal
and i think that's because there are no
words
it helps a lot more and i love the i
love the fact that he doesn't take the
hammer because he's like that's yours he
picks up a big candlestick and just
starts his own and that's
beau's way of saying
i'm your dude let's [ __ ] up this house
together
use my language
uh i could talk to you guys all day i
have a million more questions i'm
obsessed with this show you are electric
in it your chemistry together is hands
down one of the biggest standouts of
season two so congratulations and we
hope to see you for season three